[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice dr
john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the ever
popular dr john dolone show on ramsey
networks is my co-host today as we talk
about your relationships your boundaries
your mental health your career your job
and even your money we talk about you
right in front of you right here on the
ramsey show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five we're going to start off to
this hour with uh new york city calling
wait a minute i'm gonna get this right
there it is uh khadidra is with us hey
khadira how are you
hi i'm well thank you for having me sure
what's up in your world
so i have a significant amount of
student loan debt it's around sixty
seven thousand
i also have
around nineteen thousand twenty thousand
in a personal loan repayment as well as
about five thousand in credit card debt
i just received a twenty thousand dollar
bonus from my job and i want to know
what makes the most sense do i apply it
to
the
student loan or do i
pay off the personal loan what makes the
most sense for me that's a good question
thank you for being a listener we
appreciate it and a new listener at that
so um here's what we teach and then the
more important thing is why we teach it
all right we want you to get out of debt
as fast as you possibly can and
apparently you're moving that direction
since you gave me all your debts and
then said i've got some money um and the
reason we want you to get out of debt as
fast as you possibly can is that frees
up your most powerful wealth building
tool which is your income
okay so we're in agreement we want to
get out of that the fastest possible way
we also want to get out of debt in a way
that causes us to actually finish the
plan so
this only works
this suggestion of mine the answer to
your question only works if it's if it's
not the only thing you do but it's part
of the whole thing that you do as you
plug into this whole ramsey ecosystem on
money okay so within that ecosystem
you're gonna live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else you're gonna sell so much stuff
the kids think they're next you're gonna
live on nothing you're not going out to
eat you're not going on a
vacation you're going to pour every
dollar at this debt with great intensity
and then you're going to get out of debt
okay now if you're going to do all of
that then this works if you're going to
screw around with it and ish it
it's not going to work
so i got to give you that caveat to the
advice now what we in that context what
we teach people to do is list your debts
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything with the smallest debt and
attack the smallest debt and then the
next and then the next and then the next
that gives you a sense of
traction
a sense of power
a sense of destiny that this is going to
work it gives you hope
and so i'm gonna list your five thousand
dollars worth of credit cards and i'm
gonna pay them off and then i'm gonna
pay the rest of it on the personal loan
and as soon as i get that personal loan
gone i don't have any credit card
payments i don't have any personal loans
then i'm going to attack the
student loans with a vengeance because
you're going to pay off all but 5 000 of
the personal loans and you're going to
cut up your stupid credit cards so they
didn't grow back
okay just making sense
yes it's making sense
okay there's a lot of recurring payments
that i need to get rid of on my credit
card so that i can do that yeah well
just move them over your debit card yeah
or in you know that's what i use i use a
debit card and you got to move them over
but chomp them up
get rid of them and if you take twenty
thousand and apply it to twenty and five
then that leaves only five thousand on
the personal loan did i do that math
right
yeah okay
and you make how much ninety
no i make one sixty oh great okay so
you're gonna knock out that other five
in like 20 minutes right
yeah yeah and then we're gonna knock out
the student loans in less than one year
and you're going to be free how long
have you had these student loans
since 2015. okay it's time for sally mae
to leave your life
seven years is too long for her to be
invading your space
yes
so john the power of paying off the
smallest to largest that incremental
progress that's exactly psychology about
that john has a phd in psychology so i
can ask him about these things yeah so
do you
you're either overwhelmed or the joy is
welling up inside you and you can't
speak which one is it
i'm a little overwhelmed okay i'm a
little nervous so
just to just to reiterate what dave just
said by the end of today you're gonna
have no credit card debt
you're gonna have five grand left on a
family loan that with your income
hopefully you can go to the bank and get
that five grand and you're out of that
one too
and then after today because of one free
phone call and because you're ready to
knock this thing out then you just gotta
tackle the last big ugly hairy dog there
and move your credit card cut your
credit cards up and get a debit card
right and then you're ready to rock and
roll
that's i there's an intensity to this
though and you feel that is that what's
a little overwhelming
yes i absolutely need to be rid of all
that yeah so here's what we have
discovered and this is for the benefit
of all our listeners but also for you
what we've discovered is personal
finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
you've been you're a smart lady i can
tell by talking to you just how
articulate you are you've been trying to
fix this with your intellect and it's
not an intellectual problem
it's a i'm get pissed off at sally may
and i'm kicking the old woman out of my
freaking house
problem
there's an emotion a visceral
move to this and that is tied to the
success of people who get out of debt
you cannot fix
a problem that you made emotionally with
an intellectual fix you have to fix it
with an emotional change and that
applies to
marital issues that applies to most
mental health issues you can't think
your way out of most of these problems
you can get a plan
cognitively but then you got to go do
you got to go be different you got to
act different right little by little by
little yeah good that's a great call and
that's for you know her call is for all
of you
out there so
here's the deal
they actually did a study at
northwestern university
that uh studied the idea of paying off
your debts highest interest rate first
versus smallest to largest
and the conclusion of this university
study was
dave ramsey's right
and we're like well we kind of already
knew that because we already taught 10
million people how to do this while you
guys were doing this study up there in a
vacuum but um dave i've been at those
tables where we're discussing data and
everyone
kind of hangs their head like oh man we
didn't expect these finding i just
imagined that table they were going to
show you no i i well i don't know i
don't know whether they
if they if they they did at least come
out and publicly
they put it out okay and they literally
did say all this time ramsay's been
right yeah you know so i don't know
whether they were trying to prove me
right or prove me wrong but it doesn't
matter we already knew we were right
because we had more proof social text
than proof texts than they had so we
already knew that we had more data than
they would have ever seen with a number
of people that have actually done this
but that's the thing guys you've got to
have a level of hope and you know your
behaviors your impulse your lack of
control your disorganization your
immaturity your inability to delay
pleasure these are all things that you
got to fix it's called growing up
and when you do and you apply a that a
behavior fix
to getting out of debt you'll get out of
debt but when you try to intellect your
way out of a behavior problem you can't
do it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
john's brand new book is called own your
past change your future it is on
pre-sale right now for only twenty
dollars and john's got two phds 20 years
of counseling experience packed it into
an easy to understand book this book is
going to have a positive impact on
everyone everyone should read this book
i got to tell you i personally
um it's changed some of the language i'm
using not only with you guys but inside
my own head as well and that's just from
me reading through the manuscript
because it's got my name on the
publishing and so i want to know what
the flip we were saying before we put it
out there and it turns out you know
it'll help like a 30 year old that's
looking to sharpen their mind this is
not a thing you have to like
this is a book for crazy people it's not
it's a book for all of us have a little
crazy and we all could adjust it a
little bit that's right all of us have
some things we could polish up and just
you know a little more peace a little
less anxiety all of us could adjust the
way we're looking at certain things and
you give a framework for doing that and
that's why i think this book is going to
blow up yeah there's a lot of books out
there that are scholars talking to
scholars and they're fine and they're
good and they're important and there's a
lot of books out there on
what i call way outside the bell curve
for some significant mental illness for
folks who are practitioners there's
almost nothing for folks who are just
trying to live life better
have a better conversation that's right
with yourself that's right have a better
conversation with uh your friend i mean
the people you love right you know in
our world today we were talking about
this before we went on the air um
you know the number of times that two
people can just sit down and
almost enjoy a good argument just
because we can have a good discussion
because we still love each other we did
before we started and after we finished
the argument we still think you're wrong
but i still love you of course and but
everybody you have to hate everybody and
you have to chop off everything
in our divisive world out there it's
like well you said you you you you you
have a mask or you don't have a mask and
so i'm pissed at you for the rest of
your life you know i mean it's like
people are losing their dadgum minds out
well they're gone man and so you know we
need some new tools
to control ourselves and also to
interface with other people and just to
walk it back you know what i mean we've
laughed internally and not laughed but
we've thought really we look at the
number of conversation cards we've sold
like is that where we are and the
reality is yep that's where we are that
we we're starting over kind of like old
school you gotta get a thousand bucks
let's just start there right that's
where we are when it comes to
relationships and our mental health
right now and let's do it and let's just
stop pretending let's stop walking
around the problem let's go right
through the middle of it well and and to
my knowledge none of our leadership team
or publishing team has significant
mental health problems right to my
knowledge and every one of them were
touched
including me and informed and given new
tools by reading this book own your past
change your future you know we've taught
god's and grandma's ways of handling
money for 30 years here at ramsey and
john's doing the same thing now god's
and grandma's ways of doing
relationships doing mental health it is
a complex topic but uh people that are
smart can take a complex topic and make
it simple around here we call it putting
the cookies on a shelf where everyone
can reach them so pre-order your copy
today at ramseysolutions.com it's 20
bucks you're going to get the audio
version of the book the ebook version of
the book and you're gonna get one month
of free weekly therapy sessions from the
fine folks that better help who have
come alongside that makes this 20
purchase an unbelievable deal so ramsey
solutions.com and check it out the new
book coming out in april get it
pre-ordered now to get all the goodies
on your past
change your future our question today
comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping with the two new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from david in oregon david writes
i've been paying the bills but not doing
a proper budget since my wife and i got
married i thought i could do it and we
coasted by for about 10 years then kids
came time flew by and we accumulated
thirty thousand dollars in debt i never
made my spouse part of the process and
held her off so she didn't have to feel
the financial burden
she has a quote-unquote feeling that
something isn't right when i won't let
her see our finances and she's right i
recently read one of dave's tweets look
at you using twitter to help people i
didn't know that was possible it said if
you're in a committed relationship
you've got to play with all of your
cards face up how do we start over and
do it right this time
this is a moment this is it one of those
cool mirrors a really great question i
love this question
so dave in my life
when i've i've had several of these in
my marriage over 20 years
it always starts with me saying
we need to have a discussion
and i need to i need to
invite you into some hard stuff that's
going on in my heart mine my actions
whatever and i start with i'm sorry i've
been living this way and i haven't
brought you along i've left you out i've
excluded you whatever the thing is
and
i want to invite you in to help make
this right and she's very right to feel
betrayed she's very right or her
feelings are going to be her feelings
but it starts with somebody
turning the lights on turn the music off
and saying i was wrong and i'm sorry
let's start here
yeah
and i i got to tell you that i mean i've
walked couples through this
and sometimes i played marriage
counselor for five minutes in the middle
of a coaching session on money uh in
this
and if he will just i got 99 percent of
the time if if dude you got the perfect
heart she's got the right heart actually
both of you do for this for this to be
successful and so
i would just say look i have screwed
this up i'm sorry
the reason i screwed it up was it
started off with i was just going to
take care of it i was going to man up so
you didn't have to worry about it
and then it got out of control and i was
ashamed
that i didn't
do it right
and that caused me to even become
more guarded of it and i should have
just brought the whole thing to you and
we should have worked on it together and
i really screwed up but i screwed up
because i was trying to
be the man and carry this for you and
that's not the right way to be a man by
the way
and i was trying and then when it fell
apart and i couldn't do it then i was
ashamed of myself and i didn't want to
didn't want to reveal to you that i had
screwed up because i felt i felt stupid
and so if he just says that which is
what he said right but if he just says
that to her she's going to be really
forgiving oh man and
this usually when i see a couple like
this there's something underneath it
which
there's something about the way they
communicate in this home that she
doesn't like so if this is
my wife
she will
not say hey i've got a feeling she will
insert herself into this process right
so there's something about it could be
that they've been married five years and
you've been married 20. that's well even
better ten years first five years sharon
would have been this
now sharon would be like what
it's going
very similar here it's different now
yeah after 40 years you know we we kind
of cut through the bull you know so
those one hour conversations are six six
seconds yeah it's like
not i have a feeling it's like ah you're
scheming and scamming what the crap's
going on
but something here is going to have to
change in how they do because this isn't
just going to show up money's going to
show up with kids it's going to show up
let's let's come up with a new way of
doing business of loving each other and
and here here's the lesson that you get
out of this and you learn it through the
money lens and it will affect your whole
marriage to your point and the lesson
that you get out of it that's so
beautiful is this that everything you do
is going to be better when you do it
together right
instead of you trying to give her the
gift of her not having to worry right
that is not a real gift and every
everything that's a falsehood have a
feeling uh hey something's not right
develop a language that y'all can ask
each other that question it just does
away with it right right away just goes
away it's poof
you deal with it you move on oh and by
the way this also tells us that your
wife has really really good intuition
yep and so the next time she has a
feeling
about the car salesman but you think you
want to buy the truck anyway you need to
get off the lot yep because her feelings
are probably pretty intuitive probably
pretty accurate yeah it might be god
speaking through her i've learned that
the hard way yeah i
if sharon says sharon's southern so she
says she it's a seven syllable word i
got a bad feeling and if she gets a bad
feeling and i go against it cost me 10
grand at least
i just quit doing it i just don't go
against those feelings they're expensive
i've been wrong almost every single time
i just i mean we have to get on the same
page and i i don't violate that i mean
i'll question her i'm like was it last
night's pizza i mean why are you having
a feeling but but she's like no no this
guy i just think he's a bad guy i don't
know what it is but i can't put my
finger on it but i got a bad feeling oh
geez we're getting away from that guy
oh he he's asap gonna find out later
what happened with him
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage stephen
and melissa are with us hey guys how are
you doing well pretty good dave how are
you good to have you guys where do you
all live eat in ohio eaton ohio where is
eaton uh just outside dayton oh okay i
can do that i can i know where dating is
all right good good to have you guys
welcome to nashville how much debt have
you paid off 55 000. all right way to go
how long did this take
uh seven months
that's quick
and your range of income during that
time 140 000. cool what do y'all do for
a living i'm a cnc machinist and i'm a
financial analyst cool what's a cnc
machine i know cnc music factory i don't
know cnc machinist what's that uh it's
basically instead of a manual machining
uh basically computer programs and we're
cutting up parts company i work for
actually cuts uh silicon parts that go
in the process of making computer chips
oh wow that's good
make more make more yeah we're trying
very busy year all right so yeah really
so catch up catch up all right cool man
very cool what kind of debt was the 55
000 it was our mortgage oh
you had a tiny little mortgage yeah yeah
we had a large down payment
a large down payment and what's this
house worth about 175 yeah
how old are you two i'm 31 and i'm 29
and you have a paid for house y'all are
so weird
wow weird people
it's the least weirdest thing about us i
like it
way to go you guys how fun
so what in the world who sets up
themselves to put that kind of down
payment and be a 100 debt-free house and
everything by the time you're freaking
30 years old where does all of this come
from how do you learn this where's your
story of ramsey what in the world uh
well i've listened to you for about 10
years now and i never had any consumer
debt
i'd gone to a couple of your live events
and when me and steven started dating a
few years ago i was trying to get him to
come aboard which he did he paid off his
car and
agreed we would never get another car
loan and all kinds of things like that
so we were pretty much wanting to pay
cash for a house
and i'll let you finish well uh she was
working multiple jobs i was working my
job plus we both were doing ins cart and
pretty much all our free time that we
were allowed to
and
you know we were going to cash flow it
and we were surprised a little early
about our daughter arriving you know
sooner than expected so we decided if we
found a house beforehand that we you
know fell in love with we'd go ahead and
get a small mortgage with the gold
painted off within a year which you know
seven months later
wow yeah so how old is your little baby
10 months oh so you move in three months
before yeah
you bought the house three months before
the baby came yeah well you're brave
and you're brave moving a pregnant woman
into a new house dude
you called my
well done wow and we found a house that
we loved so yeah it worked out perfectly
yeah and you had a plan to go ahead and
knock it out yeah and that's pretty cool
yep so i mean that so you say you grew
up listening and then you converted him
when you all got married yeah so uh who
were your biggest cheerleaders people
outside of y'all looking at like you
like you've lost your minds uh we're
pretty private people so not too many
people know about it honestly um but we
definitely try to like preach debt-free
living to anybody who will listen and
our families
i'm sure are proud of us so
[Laughter]
we think they are
so i'm just imagining at the machine
shop you make a good living you work
hard
there's some dudes with some big trucks
and some jacked up jeeps and the one guy
with every parking lot's got the guy
with the tesla now and then you're
rolling in with your old and you're just
dumping all your money into the house
yeah what are you doing with people
uh for taurus yeah see you're the guy
with the tourists right i used to have
it with the paid for house that's that's
what i'm saying
right yeah so
how do you deal with the guys who's
giving it to you all the time
just stay focused i mean we're on our
own little journey you know it's not
about what they have or
what we can have you know what that's
what we can afford what we can live with
so i know you make silicone chips if you
can bottle what you just said and sell
it you will be a trillionaire okay good
for you man
yeah this idea that it's like none of
their business i don't care this
i'm getting out of debt and whatever
they want to do is okay it's just
one of the keys to becoming wealthy is
you quit caring what other people think
i'm just saying one of the keys to
winning earth is what you just said so
good for you
wow
way to go you guys absolutely incredible
so what is the key to staying you guys
are like preventative medicine mainly
you almost are completely stayed out of
debt
and and getting out of that what are the
what's the big key
uh definitely staying focused on your
you know your joint goal um i wouldn't
we wouldn't have been able to do it if
the other person wasn't on board
definitely making sure that you're in
alignment with each other and you have
the same goals and the same passion to
live you know your life later on
um you know without debt and again like
he said with contentment with what we
have
so you had rent before
yeah and now you have no payments in the
world exactly have you got that one
check yet when you don't owe anybody
anything and you just stare at your own
money yes yeah we paid it off in
september so we've been living that way
a little while how does that feel yeah
it feels great it's nice
it's been great to go on vacation and
not really worry you know we have a
budget of course but um not really being
concerned you can kind of do anything
you want to do yeah i mean life is
pretty good how did y'all grow up with
money
i was terrible with money i you know
i've worked this job for over 12 years
but it was just
paycheck to paycheck spend all i can
take a lot of vacations or
you know go to casino whatever yeah
yeah i i grew up with um i forget the
way rachel freezes it but money was not
a
hot topic it wasn't a good uh a good
thing to really bring up so
that's probably why i'm so um you know i
want to make sure that we're secure and
our future children and our our daughter
is saved it was not it was if it was
brought up it was explosive exactly yeah
okay so when you when you think about
your childhood and then you look at that
beautiful little girl
what's it feel like to know
we have just done a 180 on her
trajectory it feels great i keep trying
to tell him like we could pay for her
first house you know when she gets
married or at least help out a lot with
it so that maybe they don't ever have a
mortgage and our grandchildren may not
have a mortgage what a friend of mine
did that he made the kids sign a letter
promising they would never borrow a dime
and he'd give him a house yeah and he
said they're millionaires by the time
they were 20 right i mean 25 right not
20 but 25 and it's just pretty
incredible yeah wow
you guys are cool
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you number one bestseller that is
the next chapter in your story for sure
if you're not there yet you'll be there
soon and uh of course a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away and disrupt someone cause a holy
ruckus with that you probably got
somebody in mind needs to read that that
ought to go do what you guys have done
all right well let's get the uh young
lady into the picture and how what's her
name and how old is she uh raylynn and
she is 10 months 10 months oh look oh
and janelle just didn't want to hand her
over to that one just keep holding her
over there that was bouncing around her
knee that was so cute
so cute well done stephen and melissa
and raelynn dayton ohio 55 000 paid off
in seven months oh by the way that was
their house they're a hundred percent
debt free at 29 and 31 years old making
140 a year count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh baby that is awesome
man their future is bright i remember
i mean i just remember when josephine
was that little
oh my goodness watching them hold their
baby yeah
it goes so fast and you guys have just
changed her
existence and she doesn't even know
the level of stress that's not in their
house
and will never be in their house because
the number one thing people fight about
the number one stress point in marriage
the number one cause of divorce money
fights money problems money stresses and
that daughter is gonna never feel it
that daughter when she goes to
elementary school in middle school high
school she's got two parents who are
like we don't care what people think
this is who we are and she's gonna be
firmly rooted in all aspects of her
identity man that's unbelievable oh
you're setting up but you're setting up
a whole winning thing here that is way
beyond just paying off the house well
done well done well done wow they're
heroes man rock stars i'm so proud of
them
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host alexander is in charleston south
carolina hi alexander how are you
[Music]
i'm doing well dave i gotta say it's an
honor to speak to the both of you you
too sir how can we help
uh i just had a quick question because
uh my wife and i started doing the baby
steps over again i got out of debt
before we got married i paid for her
ring in cash and then we got married and
brought her student loan debt in
so we're starting from square one and
you say at the with the baby step two
you should stop all investments does
that mean i should turn my uh my
employees savings account that they use
for my 401 k should i just turn that off
for now until i'm done yes sir
okay
now here's why
okay
it's not really
that much difference in the math
but there's something that happens in
your brain when you go whole hog when
you completely focus on a single goal to
the detriment of all other goals
when you completely sell out
for getting out of debt it increases not
only the probability that you're going
to get out of that but the speed at
which you do it and it does free up a
little bit of money the money that was
going into the 401 k temporarily is not
going there temporarily it is going to
your debts but more than anything it's
you going
i'm in i'm doing this and there's
something about that level of
uh focus that level of commitment that
breaks things loose in your life because
you start you go you look over there and
you go well we can't really buy that
thing because that's going to mean one
more month that i'm in debt and one more
month i'm not in the 401 k and that's
pissing me off because i want to be in
my 401 k so
it just keeps dialing it back down and
focusing it back down to where you're
putting blinders on your financial life
and on your the psychology of the
situation to be able to focus
exclusively on one thing john what is
the power that comes from that that i'm
describing
i'm just listening i'm thinking of
this is just pure unadulterated rage
right so alexander just thinking about
pausing does that does that make your
heart rate go up
it it does and it doesn't because like i
said i've been you know gazelle the day
before and i got the wife to join the
cause but you know it's it's different
now for me because you know i'm married
now i got a family that i'm gonna take
care of we're thinking about expanding
our family in a couple of years and you
know so we want to be free right and so
let this like it does and it doesn't it
does right and you're a cool cucumber
like nah it's cool
it does and it should right and it's a
good kind of anger that's right it's a
it drives action yeah it's a righteous
rage man like i'm not gonna ever find
myself in this situation ever again
we're not going to i love how you're
changing your pronouns we're not going
to right we're going to keep going and
going and going
mary's in louisville kentucky hi mary
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call
my question is
in 2014
i went through a nasty divorce
and 2015 i rented for a year and then i
bought a
condo uh in a couple weeks i'm getting
ready to sell my condo and last year i
remarry
so uh the house that my husband was
living in uh together we
moved in obviously we got married
between 2021 uh he owes we owe like 68
000 on the house
and
um
when i sell this condo i'm going to get
about
90 000 from the sale of the condo so i
don't know whether to just go ahead and
say let's pay off the house
or should i invest it in our retirement
well with the exception of the fact that
you've been through a lot of pain
and um
so you're probably a little gun shy
uh but if if you if let's just say let's
dial this back and say okay you call me
up you're 25 years old and you're brand
new married
and you've never been married before and
never had the scars of of the hurt and
the pain in the broken heart of a
divorce
and uh all of that and you call me up
the question's a no-brainer we pay down
the house
right okay so that's the answer of the
right way to do this financially but if
i'm in your shoes that might be hard for
me to do and i might want some checks
and balances in place
uh because um
you know i've just got these scars and
so the checks and balances would be that
your name is on the deed on the new
house and that there's a will
that both of you sign that in the event
of his death the house is yours in the
event of your death the house is his
and uh we're not there you know former
kids from former marriages or whatever
are not getting his kids aren't getting
at your 90 grand that you paid down on
his house and you know we got to have a
lot of clarity and legal documents on
all of that and if he's unwilling to do
that then that's going to spook me
yeah and
in something else i've got a 403 b and
i've got an ira
and i have one son he has three kids
and before we got married he brought up
he said before we get married i just
want you to know that
something happens to you
uh
your money is going to go to your son he
doesn't have to even think about
splitting it with my three that's just a
given well then you need to change the
beneficiary on your 401k or 403b
to name your son
yes i did okay i did all right then
that's already taken care of and that's
fine so he so your your husband your new
husband
gets it
yes we need to discuss then what what's
going to happen with the house we've
already discussed what's going to happen
the retirement it's going to the kids
okay but what's going to happen with the
house that we own together and it was
yours before but now i'm putting 90
grand into it have you all had that
conversation already
we've kind of
jumped around it haven't really come
right out and said okay we're going to
do this yeah you need to you need to
know that your 90 grand is protected and
that you own the house when he dies or
you don't put the money in the house and
i i care less about the the dollar
amount and i care more about that you're
not homeless if he passes away right
or that his kids don't come out and say
hey that house is ours we're going to
sell it
and we'll give you your 60 grand back
but you're homeless yeah it's it's just
good clarity and you know it it could be
the one thing that you guys decide okay
this is something we are doing together
to the exclusion of our children his
retirement goes to his kids your
retirement goes to your kids but
this this piece of the wealth we're
going to is our new life and we're going
to do this house together and basically
basically you're buying into this house
and this gives you a vision for the
future it's something you can share on
that if you don't do that i kind of
think you got a problem yeah you might
want to sell that house and the two of
you do go buy a house that you can own
together and go into the future
uh if he's stuck on his house kind of
thing i don't think he is though this
guts scott sounds like he's pretty
open-handed i i like him already so it's
good stuff bill is in mobile hi bill
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can i help
i have a question a tax question uh
relating to a car that i sold last
summer
i bought it three years ago
um pre-owned and i think it's a limited
edition sports car i think it's
considered a collectible
i paid
about
40 000 above msrp when i bought it and
then i ended up selling it
for about 18 000 less than i bought it
for so i'm wondering
um
can i write that 18 000 off um against
other capital gains no that's a loss off
that no
because you drove the car it's not a
collectible you drove the car
it's your daily dude it's your daily
driver right yes sir yeah you just
bought a car and lost money on cars all
you did and you can't what kind of if
it's if it's a business
you could do that if you had if you're
in the business of collecting cars and
that would mean the car was like sitting
in the garage it wasn't a daily driver
and you're in it's an investment and
you're buying the car as an investment
and you do you regularly trade cars as a
part of your ongoing club car
collectible business collectible car
business yeah you could write off a loss
then but i don't think you can you could
double check with a tax advisor to be
sure i'm not very good at taxes so i
could be wrong but i don't think you can
so i'm with john what kind of car what
is this
it was a course 911 gt3 rs oh my god so
what have we learned here what what wait
a minute what color was it
it was black with uh green
accents
that's awesome is a beast of an
automobile dude the the studio is
getting warm for those of you listening
i can't i can't believe you that that
thing didn't bring more than that
in this weird market
it's currently bringing about 250 yeah
um so
you just got burned on the up sale
yes sir i i i if i would have sold it
private sale um i think i could have
sold a price for more than i bought it
for but um
oh
there it is okay so you could have got
out of it but you flip flipped it into
the next deal
wow
well i don't think you can double check
your tax cut to be sure but i'm pretty
sure
that i'm right i've been wrong before
though this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king in the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
baloney ramsey personality best-selling
author host of the dr john dolone show
is my co-host today we'll be taking your
questions about your relationships
mental health your anxiety your
boundaries your family your job your
career your money your wealth whatever
it is you want to talk about basically
we're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in the call is free some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it
gene is with us in cincinnati hi gene
welcome to the ramsey show
hi i'm so excited to talk to you you too
what's up
so my husband and i um need your advice
um
about
a subject that we're conflicted on so
um we have been going to a church um
for about a year we both had our own
churches we got married several years
ago and and it took us a while to find
our church and we're very comfortable
with this church
but um we're conflicted on whether we
should
help with something over and above our
tithe and we're conflicted on that so
i'm calling to see if you can help us
wade through this so why are you
conflicted um
well our pastor
um
he addressed the church recently to
explain this church is about 10 years
old or so 10 12 years old
and he explained that
when they
started this church they started
storefront and then
they found this property and they
borrowed
money to
purchase this property and to do
renovations
and so he said it was
350 to 400 000
total
and um he came before the church um
recently to say that they owe maybe 250
000 or so on the church
and
um he would like us as a church
as as we can his his goal is to try to
get this debt paid off
but he also indicated he would like to
expand the church
and build a bigger sanctuary etc
without explaining whether or not
they're going to borrow to do that
and i
am dave ramsey fight
and so my husband and i are debt-free
and we're totally um in 100 agreement on
that and um we also type
and i want to help but i don't want to
help them pay this deck off to help them
go get another loan
and there's not a lot of transparency in
this church we've been there for a year
we don't know what tithes are there's
our former churches both of our former
churches i came from a very large church
he came from a very
small church
or very transparent about contributions
tithing and then where that money was
going and we both came from debt-free
churches does the church come
if you went in and met with a pastor uh
and asked for the annual budget would
they give it to you
well that's what i said to my husband i
that's what how i think we need to
approach that he he feels like it's
he's uncomfortable
it's almost like he feels like he's
questioning our pastor no and i and i
said no i i think we have a right to
know where this money's going and then
i'm uh what we call around ramsey i'm
invested in this i'm a stakeholder
okay and so yeah you know you're you're
a stakeholder you're you're you're a
stockholder in a sense you're a tither
and so it's not um you're not
questioning someone's character and you
can make that plain you just go listen
we just want to know we've been tithing
and it brought up the discussion and we
just want to make sure you know we're
real diligent with our finances it
appears you guys are
and love to see a copy of the budget
um
i will not tithe and attend a place that
will not allow the tither to see the
budget
because that i i've just been around i
mean 50 000 churches have taught
financial peace university so believe me
we've seen some stinkers
okay and i don't you know there's only
one reason to hide something
or to not disclose something something's
wrong that's the only reason there's i
think i think they're gonna i think
they're gonna let you see the budget i
don't think they're going to be a
problem with it it's very standard but
they just don't make it as a big deal
about publishing it everywhere maybe
they don't want in the paper or whatever
i don't blame them
but but if you went in and sat down had
lunch and say hey i need to ask you a
couple questions we want to give to this
new project and we want to continue to
be tithers we've made this our home
church we love you we trust you uh as a
matter of just our normal course of
business we'd like to look at the budget
and i want to ask you about your plans
to continue to borrow because i'm an
anti-debt freak
and i just i just want to know about
that and we're not going to leave the
church over it we're not going to be mad
at you we're not going to cause
divisiveness we're not going to gossip
we're not going to work against you we
just want to know what's going on and so
how and and so we can feel comfortable
supporting the whole process and to hear
what dave just said there which is
masterful which is this is our
our philosophies is our problem
not yours we're not coming at him guns
of blazing but this is how we do life
and we want to see if if this is
something we want to partner with
and they want to be a good steward yeah
well you don't have to say that because
it indicates to him that he's a bad
steward if he doesn't do it your way is
there something else that you're not
finding trustworthy there it feels like
there's something beneath this it's not
that we we love this poster we believe
that he is um the real deal he is
amazing cool
how big a church is
it's um
maybe three four hundred people it's a
smaller church than i'm used to okay
well he's the things he's doing now are
going to lay the foundation for you to
go to 3 000 or they're going to keep you
at 300.
that's what he wants he wants to grow
this i know but he's not going to grow
it if he doesn't make the decisions you
and i are talking about properly
right because it is part of the process
you have to lay a foundation literally
uh in order to start building until you
know exactly we've talked about that you
talk about that the bible talks about it
and well
that's all numbers the numbers on
churches
let me tell you it's it's like 90 of the
pastors are gone within five years of a
multi-million dollar building project
they don't make it
it ends up costing them their job
90 or they leverage it to go to a bigger
church well something but it's just
they're they're not there they don't see
it through
and so i was at a church the other day
that that uh i'm friends with and i'm
friends with the pastor i'm friends with
the last five pastors they've had that's
how old i am and so and this guy is
still saddled with the debt of a guy
four pastors ago
from a project and he's he's swimming in
it man and it's a mess so i don't
believe in it i'm with you but i'm also
i'm also don't tell people to leave a
church just because of debt i don't
and i don't know i don't want to leave
this church i'm not and i'm not i don't
want to i don't want to pay off debt so
he can go borrow more money and i don't
blame you i don't blame you i wouldn't i
i could i could keep tithing there
if i were you and keep attending there
if i could see the budget
and not participate in the debt
reduction or building program because
it's going to be end up with more debt
if he says no we're going to borrow
i could do that with good conscience i'd
be fine
but i'm not i'm with you i can't give to
something where the bank is going to be
the beneficiary of it not god's kingdom
and god's kingdom has
absolutely nothing to do with banks i am
sure of that
shots fired
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
people are craving connection they're
craving community they're craving the
energy that only comes from humans
being with
other humans and we know that we hear
you we need it too
uh we got to get back out there people
we got to get back to your cities we've
been you coming to your cities for 20 30
years and we miss it and we're about to
get back at it so
first up we're going to do building
wealth live we're doing the tour
we're announcing and have almost sold
out already orlando on may the 19th
that's george campbell rachel cruz and i
oh and we're going to bring dr john
dolone and king coleman for some side
sessions as well while we're there and
then we're going to announce five more
cities one more this spring and four
more in the fall for the building wealth
live and we're bringing back to dallas
october 22nd the smart conference
yeah you're going to be smarter it's a
day-long event you will leave exhausted
and inspired and better and smarter in
every area of your life from mental
health to money to career to anything
you want to talk about we're going to
cover it that day uh amy and craig
groschel our friends from lifechurch.tv
over in oklahoma city the largest church
in america are going to do the marriage
section
for us i'm really looking forward to
having them with us the smart conference
october 22nd in dallas so far the first
building wealth live not quite sold out
orlando may 19th you can still get
tickets but you do need to get them
ramsey solutions dot com slash events
ramsay solutions dot com slash events it
is time to get back out in the real
world with people john i can't wait
so time to talk about uh james our
producer has come up with this great
idea that every so often we should
feature
some greedy rich people
because we all know that rich people are
horrible we all know that it's a
horrible thing that they're going to
hell because the camel can't get through
the eye of a needle we know that rich
people are awful that that the love of
money is the root of all evil well they
just they're they're dragging america
into the into the sewer we're just
dragging america greedy rich people
dragging america into prosperity against
its will
and it's just awful it should stop
they're greedy they're awful we've
featured several of them lately uh shaq
and some money that he gave away that
was ridiculous and worse dolly pardon it
was awful how much money she's giving
away the worst she's just ruining the
reputation of the greedy rich people and
wants kids to read this guy i got to
know this guy personally before he died
and i hate to talk bad about people that
died but he's rich larry stewart
deserves to be talked about because he's
a greedy rich guy so here's what
happened
in 1971 larry was homeless before he was
a greedy rich guy
and he was broke
no money and hungry
so he went into a diner
in houston mississippi this is known as
a small town
sat at the counter ordered a sandwich
got a sandwich finished eating the owner
of the diner was observing this guy
realized he had absolutely no money
walked around behind him
and reached under the stool that the guy
was sitting on and said hey mister i
think you dropped this and handed him a
20 bill wow
to pay for his lunch
and larry said if i ever get any money
i'm gonna do that a lot
well larry went on to move to kansas
city got in the cable business became a
multi-millionaire
and started a thing for many years no
one knew who it was he was called secret
santa
and he would dress up as santa claus
with a police escort and give away tens
of thousands of dollars a hundred two
hundred dollars at a time just walking
down the street seeing someone making
eye contact with them and going that
person needs a lift that person needs a
smile that person needs a couple hundred
bucks and so he went to uh new orleans
during after katrina he went to new york
city after um after 9-1-1 before that
many to other cities he was just find a
place where they were having a hard time
there had been some kind of a disaster
catastrophe tragedy and he would go in
to cheer everyone up as secret santa
it started in kansas city his hometown
the kansas city star followed him around
for years the newspaper trying to figure
out who he was never could find out who
secret santa was it was a big deal we
knew about it we talked about it on this
show years and years ago and then uh
sadly larry got cancer
and uh was given a death sentence
and uh and he came on the show
and we had featured him several times
but we didn't know who he was and then
he came on the show and revealed
on this show who he was
told america who he was and um
then he asked everyone to co-become
secret santas and he actually set up a
kit to show you how to do it
and that was his legacy that he wanted
to leave before he passed away and it's
estimated that larry stewart this greedy
rich guy gave away well over a million
dollars millions of dollars
as secret santa over the years but now
has inspired a whole other generation of
secret santas and we don't know who they
are but they're also of course greedy
rich people man you gritty rich people
should be ashamed of yourselves
and i'm probably not supposed to say
this but i've been on the road with you
before
and
i've seen you i've seen people's eyes
bug out just because you're so generous
with folks who are helping with bags and
things like that
which has inspired me there's something
about
hey i don't have a million dollars to
give or i can't give ten thousand
dollars this project there's something
life-giving about saying i can make this
person i'm just gonna grab this gas
especially these days i'm gonna grab the
gas i'm just gonna go stick my debit
card and this person's gas is they're
getting out of the car this mother
getting out of the car
and i'm not going to say anything other
than blessings to you i hope you have a
hope your day's a little bit better
handing somebody 100 bucks as a tip
instead of the expected two dollars
there's something about being able to do
that and seeing an entire it just they
they turn into sunshine right it's just
this because it restores it's not just
about the money it's about humanity it's
about i thought everyone's against me
and this person's not and it's something
magical man and it's infectious yeah but
the ugly rich people should stop doing
that yes yes yes middle class
middle class folks you're giving a bad
reputation to the greedy rich people
when you do this stuff i know you're
supposed to when you're unbelievably
generous and you just blow people's
minds it's just messes up the whole
the whole narrative that greedy rich
people should all be punished and give
their fair share i mean you're messing
up the narrative when you're private
jets to your special parties that you i
don't know what i'm trying to make
something up now yeah but all right hats
off to our friend who's uh graduated
onto heaven larry stewart
the original
secret santa
and uh there's there's currently secret
santas
literally all over this is so cool
that's a great legacy
well done larry well done my friend i
can't think of i mean that's a pretty
incredible legacy
you talk about fun that's fun it's such
a oh it's so fun it's unfair how fun
that is
[Laughter]
rose is in sacramento rose welcome to
the ramsay show
rose hi thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
hi so um i actually have a question i
have two little girls and one is
just about the age where she's starting
to understand the concept of money and
learning that she can
um you know make money and buy stuff for
herself that we generally don't buy for
her
is she 22 how old is she
she's five she's five okay
that's fine she's five and how's your
little girl
she's 18 months okay and your question
um so my question is i did not grow up
with a great financial advice and
thankfully my husband and i found you
when we were in our 20s and now we would
like to
kind of set our daughters up so we want
to know um do we
do you suggest us giving an allowance um
an age-appropriate allowance with the
purpose of learning to save spend
um and
give
would they be attached to chores um
because we want her to know that she has
to participate in the house like making
her bed and cleaning up her toys and we
don't really want those to be
incentive-based i agree
yeah here's what we did number one it's
age-appropriate so take it easy she's
just five
okay we're not sending them the salt
mines but
the princess address addiction okay our
goal is to do four things with money we
want to teach kids to work
age appropriately let's make up your bed
when you're four pick up your toys when
you're five okay
uh and i'll help you but you get all the
credit emotionally for doing it
um
we but and then we pay you and so
there's a connection between work and
money so you're on commission you're not
on allowance words are powerful
allowance sounds like welfare
we don't need we need to make allowance
for you you're awesome
you can bring it so bring it rockstar
toy cleaner let's do it
okay and then we teach you to save we
teach you to give we teach you to spend
wisely after we taught you to work hang
on i'm going to send you a copy of the
financial piece junior kit which will
show you how to teach your five-year-old
exactly how we taught our kids growing
up and a copy of rachel's book that i
did with her called smart money smart
kids on how to teach your kids how to
handle money it covers every bit of this
that's a really good question
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
family
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in the lobby of ramsey solutions and on
the debt free stage bobby and cindy are
with us hey guys how are you we're great
how are you great great to be here
honored to have you where do you guys
live
we live in charlotte north carolina cool
welcome to nashville thank you how much
debt have you paid off
uh we paid off 68 000. cool how long did
this take
two years good for you and your range of
income during that time
uh we were about 85 000 and we ended at
about 158 whoa nice jump what do you all
do for a living
uh bobby's a controversial contractor
home improvement and things like that
and then i'm was a finance manager with
a law with a law firm and then actually
just when we were about finished with
our our debt i went out on my own and
started my own bookkeeping business and
that's where the increase came uh a
little bit of both actually um he
received a number
it took off tremendously as soon as uh
covert hit
my construction business went crazy yeah
everybody was home so they wanted work
to be done well they happened to notice
that that stuff was broken they didn't
see it before because they weren't ever
there yeah when you visit that bathroom
10 times a day you get to see a
difference and if you're only there
twice
what kind of debt was the 68 000 you
know it's all the normal stuff but
primarily credit cards car loans some
medical bills camper loan uh you name it
it was just normal it was what we had
grown up with it was what we had always
lived with both of our lives we had
never really had any
kind of financial guidance or
um yeah nothing when i grew up my my
parents were pretty poor mm-hmm um so
it was always couponing for me
i even do it my business
he's my master couponer i love it i love
it good good so how long y'all been
married
uh seven and a half years so what
happened two years ago the pandemic and
what i mean is that kind of what woke
you up or what was the wake-up call not
really i think you know our journey
started kind of a couple years before
that we actually had around 90 000 in
debt
and you know but over five years we
realized like we had barely moved that
needle you know we maybe moved at twenty
thousand dollars so the more people we
were making seemed like the more we were
spending yeah we just kept on going kept
living up to the lifestyle and and just
you know you you think it's normal but
you're really just playing a show game
of you know you pay off one thing and
you think oh i've got an extra 300 on my
budget we'll go get a camper you know so
you know you just you just you know
stupid builds upon stupid yeah over and
over and we
when we first moved here from
massachusetts where we're from
uh we came here and we were here for
about a year but as we came to the lord
and it changed everything yeah a lot of
things changed and and it was up to
about three years ago that
i found out that this is not my money
this is the lord's money yeah and what
are we going to do with this so it that
started the ball going
really being a good steward of
recognizing that you know the money
wasn't ours it was a gift and a blessing
from the lord so how do we that flipped
the switch to cause just get intense it
did and then you got involved in this
and she was talking about you and i'm
like this is dave ramsey
this is another scam what are you doing
now
[Music]
you know and i think the thing for both
of us is you know um you know bobby
didn't really i think get fully engaged
but he trusted me to do it and i think
you know we hear so much about everybody
having their budget meetings and doing
all of this stuff together and our
journey was a little bit different we
weren't really so much on the budget
component of it i certainly used the um
the ever dollar app
which by the way you need to rebrand
that as the every penny app because
i'm telling you i was so intense on
using that app and you know if the
electric bill was you know 30 cents over
i was adjusting it in the every dollar
app and then finding that 30 cents
someplace else to either spend it or or
to um save some place out so and i just
went along with her you know i i
i actually just said there you go okay
yeah take over because it stayed out of
the way i i did i really did you know i
did i did
and that was for our vacation money too
so yeah yeah yeah he loves to anything
he saves on a coupon he takes that money
that's his own envelope system and he
kind of puts it aside and says okay now
how much money do we have in the you
know in the uh the vacation fund here so
how does it feel now that you're free
incredible it's just really
life-changing i gotta pinch myself every
morning i get up i am telling you
i i'm 66 67 whatever it is but
i wish i was their age
when this happened yeah you know what my
life would be right now but you know i
can't cry over that no but
here i am at this age so
that's why i can do it anybody can do it
oh yeah it's incredible well and i think
the other thing that happens when you no
longer have that debt not only does it
you know it changes you know like like
romans tells us you know we are not to
conform to this world and i think that
the way the world views money is that's
what we were doing we were conforming to
the world view of it's okay to have debt
it's okay to not have a future
and to suddenly have a future and to be
able to have that freedom um just by
being different um it's it's it's bold
to be
a christian in this day and age but it's
also bold to being free and so for us i
think it was a combination it walks hand
in hand with how we are being good
stewards but also what we're doing um
for our future we've come we've become
the people that we should have been
that we wanted a long time that we
wanted to be yes but i think the other
thing too is you know how we're using um
our resources now you know bobby moved
his sister
from
florida to portland oregon so talk about
going from one end of the country to the
other
but that took two weeks and you know a
year ago or two years ago we would have
never been able to have even considered
the generosity of time and effort that
it took to do that because that would
have meant two weeks of income out of it
we're able to do things like that we
help our church we help our family
i said i think you had a picture of my
granddaughter you know while he was in
portland i went up and took care of my
granddaughter for the weekend and you
know just to be able to have those type
of experiences
um and it's never been able to do that
before bobby hi special this question's
burning a hole in my heart
how can you run a construction business
without 120 000 truck loan
is that possible she's got the truck
i was given a 98 chevy suburban by one
of our our church members church members
free and it's still still get the job
done i have that to this day that's all
i use you're a magician my brother well
done
so it's funny because your last um uh
debt free couple you know they said well
they're pretty private and and we are
too and i think there are people who
have helped us without realizing they
were helping us like the gift of that
suburban you know he said i'm not going
to get anything for it as a dealer do
you want this for a work truck and and
talk about a god thing literally his old
van had just died like
15 years yeah that's incredible
so you know i'm you know the god will
god will just lay out the path for you
if you will just listen to him and you
will follow him
um and you guys have blessed us in so
many ways you're you're heroes i'm so
proud of you thank you so much
absolutely well done and we appreciate
you if it wasn't for you we i don't
think we'd be here i didn't do it no no
but you know god
yes god put you in our path for a reason
and and i think that it's important for
people to realize that you know i'm 56
he's 66 you can do this you know and and
so you know our next journey is to get
that house paid off and we've laid out
the plan that that's a five-year plan
there you go so
you know it just it builds hope upon
hope upon hope and that's what we are
praying that this will do for other
people all right well it's bobby and
cindy from charlotte north carolina we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you and a copy of total money
makeover for you because we want you to
be millionaires and give that total
money makeover book to somebody and get
them started they paid off 68 thousand
dollars in two years but i think a whole
lot more than that happened
making 85 to 158 i love it you guys are
amazing count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one we're dead
free
yes
[Applause]
wow
powerful
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225
john uh
we use a lot of uh
joke lines and um
one-liners for people's memories uh
around here for different things live
like no one else so later you can live
like no one else or better than i
deserve uh one of the things is we just
yell all the time don't be normal normal
sucks and she brought that up in that
last step free scream
um
the
do not be conformed to this world
but be transformed
by the renewing of your mind
romans 12 2. and so
what happens is if you don't want to be
normal
you have to renew your mind
and what's interesting is there's so
much data out now
that uh
confirms that biblical truth that your
mind can literally be literally
with the neural pathways can be renewed
and i love it that it's renewing that
it's a it's a
it's not for me it's not a one-stop it
didn't happen once like i'm constantly
renewing that thing right i'm constantly
learning and being around wise people
and getting new insights and
um i love that okay but your brain
literally changes neuroplasticity right
i love it neuroplastic
that thoughts have a physical shape to
them yeah they've they've
got a weight yeah there's an actual
thing that they can measure that as a
thought and a negative thought
has a place a physical place that it
lives a positive thought as a physical
place and a chemical reaction that works
through yeah as a result and
so being normal
and considering that normal in our
culture today is
overweight broke
exhausted full of anxiety
horrible relationships
kids are out of control marriage is on
the rocks
uh i hate my job
normal is it sucks yeah it's that line
just is what it is it's and i just
reject that wholesale it's not it it it
is what it is but it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be yeah it doesn't have to be
and i love what she said she said i
don't want to be normal yeah i don't
want to be like everybody else i i don't
and it what part of their journey was
not that they mathematically paid off
the debt part of their journey was they
no longer accepted normal as okay they
were they were turned inside out
yeah
and you know
the the new book you've got coming out
on your past change your future your
reform
and and your story is a way to to reset
the thought patterns in the brain right
with the new neuroplasticity
and so what we've been doing with
teaching people how to get out of debt
is reject the cultural norm
that is destroying your life by the way
and that's true of how you've been
taught to handle trauma or how you've
been taught to handle your mental health
uh your worry your anxiety your panic
attack uh how you've been taught to
handle uh boundaries with your crazy
mother-in-law isolation loneliness lack
of friendships toxic work environments
all of it right we're just told this is
just the way this is
and
life is short and then you die yep and
it is short and you die
but man there's a lot more autonomy and
a lot more transformation that can
happen in that gap and you can choose
that's right to not be conformed yeah
not be normal
with the renewing
be transformed
transformed
with the renewing of your mind and
that's true when you're getting out of
debt it's true when you're getting a new
job with ken coleman it's true with own
your past change your future and you
want a different mental health
outlook um and mental health by the way
i i think some of you are caught up to
this but some of you aren't when we're
talking about mental health around here
we're not talking about everyone that
that is cr that
anyone who wants to deal with mental
health is crazy no i want better health
i want better physical health i want
better mental
health right that's exactly what we're
sitting here talking about
neuroplasticity new thoughts renewing
your mind that is the health of your
mental it get and it doesn't mean crazy
because but mental health i kind of
people in my generation admit it's like
it's like if you go to marriage
counselor you must be about ready to
divorce if you if you say mental health
it means uh oh crazy ward gotcha and so
once you say mental health is like whoa
that's over there that's those other
people yeah but no i want to be healthy
yeah
mentally in fact i i even go as far to
say that there's really no such thing as
physical health and mental health and
relational health and spiritual health
it's all just health now that we know
enough that my thoughts actually
impact my physiology and my lack of
sleep impacts decision making all that
stuff works together man if you don't
have relationships your body's gonna be
hollering at you to get connected and
all that stuff works together but yeah i
want to have better control of my
thoughts and i want to stop waking up at
2 a.m every night after every night i
want to stop having my body take off on
me just because me and my wife get a
disagreement i want to take i want to be
a more engaged parent i want all these
things that's mental health and that's
spiritual health that's right take every
thought captive yes i'm not going to
allow
i'm going to make a conscious decision
that uh and you know our debt free
screamer in an earlier
uh segment today
how'd you do that i'm just not worried
about what the guys at work think yeah
he took a thought captive tada he took a
thought the cat that thought the thought
that i need to impress other people i
took that captive and i tossed it to the
curb
the idea that the world uh revolves
around you right just zip tie it duct
tape its mouth and throw it to the curb
yeah i mean i'm gonna take this thought
captive i'm gonna
capture it yep i'm gonna kidnap it and
throw it out of my brain yeah you know
and you physically in your mind almost
look at that i'm gonna zip tie hog tie
i don't cowboy rope i don't know what
you're gonna do how is it you capture
something in your world right
but uh and throw that thing to the curb
man and that's what he did he just said
i
wasn't worried about what they thought
no yeah it was me and her and you know
we come back to this choice thing dave
i've been through enough debt-free
screams now did you know the smile is
the same when somebody says we paid off
170 000 house and we paid off our
million dollar house the smile's the
same because it's they're smiling for
freedom right and there's this this we
get caught up in this choice of
well yeah i'll never have a hundred
million great
you can still be a millionaire you can
still be free you can still right you're
we're making these choices that um we
tend to instagram them or well that
influence right man the smile over here
is the same when people are free they
are free
and you make that choice for you and
your family in that season man and then
you get after it it's just something i
don't know i always thought freedom
would be when it was
500 million or 600 million or 100 i
watched this this freedom
on people and it's just something else
55 000 bucks yeah i paid off 60 grand
and my whole family's different now and
my whole life i became the person i
should have been that's what he said
that was a great line i became the
person i wanted to become a man it's a
great line it's just something beautiful
man that we get caught up in the choice
comparison in the chat just choose and
go for it
well i i know that there's a way that
we're going to come up with to redeem
the value in social media
but there's so much harm done yeah
that i'm i'm really comfortable just
being off of it yeah i mean i'm on it
but i got people here that run it i'm
not on it anymore i quit i just quit
yeah
i can't stand it
it drives me bananas
and um and i just i have i have to make
a choice
what i'm going to put into my brain yeah
i mean what because whatever i put in my
program if i put crap in my brain my
brain is crap yep yeah and there's
something uh you know i put hate in my
brain i just stay mad all the time well
yeah your body responds to it and ready
to fight right um this past week i was
in new york for a bunch of media
meetings and
it was the week that they had just been
released yeah
and i tell you what man it was
almost
teary-eyed
i just watched these friends and these
co-workers hadn't been together in
months coming together and having these
first time they've seen each other
physically unions since 2020 there was
laughter from their guts there was
deep conversations like truly how are
you questions not just passing
man you don't get that on this room you
don't you don't get you don't get that
on instagram you don't get that thumbs
up by the way those 43 people on
facebook aren't your real friends no
they won't be there at 2am if you have a
problem
they don't even know you're there right
they're not even sure they're who you
are but they click friend there's
something powerful dave about
getting well getting connected and being
free that's why i'm excited to go back
and do these live events again
in person yeah i mean i'm not gonna get
to have conversation with two thousand
people but i'm gonna get to be with two
thousand people with you that's right
and be with you and be with rachel
george and you know this is just who we
are here at ramsey and so some of you
don't like that and it's okay you don't
have to come
there's room
you know it's gonna sell out anyway but
we'd love to have you but you don't have
to come just come just try it let's try
it you'd be amazed what happens this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
can be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money thank you for
joining us we'll also answer questions
about your mental health your
relationships your boundaries
your
career your job we talk about all of it
right here alan's gonna start off this
hour in cheyenne wyoming hi alan welcome
to the ramsey show
hi dave hey thank you guys for taking my
call surely what's up
um okay first i retired in the end of
2012.
i'm 74 now i make about 100k
a year in pensions
the only debt that that we have is our
home which is 52 000
uh have 120 000 in the bank
i have a uh
62k in a 457 where i used to work and
i've been taking the minimum
distribution amount since 70 percent i
was 70 and a half
my question is
do i pay the 20
tax rate which is about 12k
to pay the house off or take it out out
of the bank account i'm asking because
with about five to seven interest hikes
this year predicted
uh will that clobber the change in value
over the next few years
i lost a quarter of a percent of it the
last quarter of 21 so do i take it out
now while it's still worth something
what is your income
pardon me what's your income
100k about 100k a year okay
well the 20 you're referring to is not
the tax rate
the 20 is the with the 20 is the
withholding rate unless you are in a 20
tax bracket and if you make 100k you're
not in a 20 tax bracket yeah i'm right
sorry
so the 20 is withholding so it'll be
your tax rate that you'll pay on it when
you pull it out early uh no i just use
your bank money
because it's not making anything anyway
it's 55 000 out of 120 000 and you're a
debt free write the check today
okay
okay well and that that's what i was
wondering i just didn't know about you
know the the
the interest rate
hike they're going to do over the next
few years
really that that may or may not affect
what are you invested in in your 457
in mutual funds
uh fixed income fund
oh
low risk okay well that will be affected
by the interest rate hikes um
and probably positively
uh you're not making much on it anyway
so um
yeah you got it parked very
conservatively there so i but i'm still
i'm still going to leave it alone i mean
i'm still going to let let it sit there
and grow without giving the government
uh 30 which is what you're going to give
them
there's not a wrong answer but i think
the better answer is the take the money
out 120 000 in checking write a 55 000
check and your house is debt-free with
the fixed income
withdrawal there i thought raising
interest rates would help that fund
it will it will but probably not
substantial it's probably not making
anything and it'll make double a very
little gotcha
you know so i mean but trying to beat
that doubling one you get two trying to
beat that yeah is it at a loss of 30
yeah that's the problem yeah so yeah i
just leave it alone
uh kate is with us in des moines iowa hi
kate welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are you great how can we help
oh i have a question for dr dalony i was
wondering how to process the trauma of
having
a previous toxic toxic roommate and so
that i can live with people again
walk me through what happened
well um so when
i first moved out of my parents house i
was moving in with my brother and what
was his current roommate
and
i didn't realize that
when i moved in with them that they were
involved with one another and
it caused like almost a control issue
because it was almost like two against
one and he allowed
her to
get free reign because he
she was
his partner so
it
caused some like tension and i would
like try to clean up around the house
and she would get upset that i was
cleaning up after him because she
thought that he should be able to clean
up after himself and it just made it so
it was
hard to
be anywhere except for my own room
so is the trauma
that
you
were disconnected from your brother that
your brother ended up siding with
somebody that wasn't you is that the
trauma or is it that somebody was
overbearing in your home and they were
telling you what to do
and it caught you off guard and it just
became overwhelming
probably a little bit of both like it
was very hard for me that my brother was
fighting with somebody else but also
just
if my family can do that to me
what what makes it so somebody else
wouldn't do that to me if i were to get
a roommate again there you go okay so an
important part of trauma is that our
body's responding in the present to
things that have happened in the past
okay so the idea i can hear it on you
the idea of
being alone isn't
smart it's not good it's not safe and
yet the idea of being with somebody else
if my brother can do this to me can
abandon me for some girlfriend then who
else
um then everybody's capable of this
right and so there is some truth to that
that anybody can hurt you that's all
relationship is a risk what i would tell
you is
unfortunately i've seen it
the other way whereas family is often
more likely to run over other family
members because they think they have the
right to do that or they think oh it's
just my dumb little sister or my dumb
big brother
and often agreed upon people take more
time to come up with boundaries when
it's people they don't know or when it's
new roommates so this is how we do we do
laundry this is who does the dish people
have those conversations with new
roommates and so for you the word i
would give you is number one you gotta
grieve it you gotta just own the fact
that your brother
screwed you over right and didn't treat
you like you felt you wanted to be
treated and um number two
you're gonna have to practice and i know
that sounds hard but you're gonna have
to lean into what's a relationship gonna
look like what are boundaries gonna look
like in this new relationship
and i would not hold
new roommates hostage to the way your
brother treated you it's not normal it's
not right and coming into a new
relationship with boundaries is gonna
really help that so you know if you're
not willing to help with the dishes help
with the rent help with the bills help
with the widow then um this isn't going
to be a good situation then you should
be on to the next
but it's deeply personal when your
brother hurts you isn't it
right
have you talked to him about it and his
poor choice of girlfriends
yeah have you talked to me about it
yeah it's been it's been a couple years
now and i am in an apartment by myself
now and it's just a little bit affecting
my finances because it's a little bit
more than what i want to be spending and
so
we've
talked about it were you about to say
that he's married to her now
yes he's very terrified oh see that
complicates it all
i think you got to have a hard
conversation with him and tell him it
still hurts with her it still hurts and
hopefully he'll say oh my gosh i'm so
sorry
um
and that'll let you be free of some of
this
dave
have at it try it again yeah i think you
can you can learn from this and say now
i know how to have boundaries that's
right never again never again
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is a best-selling
author and host of the dr john dolone
show
hey guys there's never been a better
time to find a job doing work you love
and that's why i can't wait to tell you
about the exciting roles that we have
open here at ramsey solutions
we are hiring about 300 folks this year
we need developers ux designers writers
to help us build the digital products
that actually change people's lives
and if you want to see what it's like to
work here well you can follow us on
instagram and facebook by searching
ramsay careers
uh all kinds of fun stuff going on here
it's a lot of hard work and a lot of
really really smart people that care
very very deeply
and so if you want to mail it in and
collect a paycheck uh probably not your
place
because we get after it
because what we're doing really really
matters to us and it matters to the
people we work for you guys that listen
so you can apply for your dream job at
ramsey solutions dot com slash careers
ramsey solutions dot com slash
careers
john one of the things that has happened
uh with this surge in real estate is a
surge in real estate values
a lot of you are sitting on a home that
is worth a whole lot more
than it was uh 20 minutes ago than it
was two years ago than it was three
years ago
there was a big hurricane and i can't
remember the name of it that hit florida
and did massive destruction before
katrina hit new orleans so several years
back in other words
and after that hurricane
state farm made the decision that they
were no longer doing
policies that covered the value of the
house
instead they're going to do policies
homeowners policies that they state the
value
and the state farm was the biggest
player in the homeowners insurance world
and so everyone followed suit
and and uh sometimes some of the
policies uh you know whereas you buy a
house for
300 000 bucks will make up a number and
you buy a homeowner's policy for 300 000
bucks cover the home you just bought
and it might have an inflation clause on
it that the next year it's a little bit
more next year it's a little bit more
but it would be it would not be unusual
for a whole bunch of you listening right
now
to have a home that you paid 300 for
that you've got 350 000 worth of
coverage with those inflation kickers on
them and the things worth 550 000 and it
burns down and you can't rebuild it you
can't build a driveway with 300 000 yeah
yeah and so
what what i'm telling you is is that you
ha it is now incumbent upon you because
the insurance business changed as of
that hurricane that i can't remember the
name of uh the insurance business
changed and it's basically stated value
plus or minus inflation kickers and the
inflation kickers aren't enough wow and
so you have to
revisit
your homeowners insurance once a year
and make sure you have the right amount
of coverage for the value of the house
how will you evaluate your your home on
an annual basis like that i mean you can
jump on just one of those websites and
look at it you're not going to be far
off but you kind of know
i got 189 thousand dollars worth of
coverage and this house is worth 600
grand our neighbors just sold their
house right yeah so you know you're like
way off yeah and so you can toss that to
your insurance provider and they they'll
they'll do a little research on it and
tell you what to cover the house for but
you need to update your coverage because
the value of your home is growing
and your policy's not you know what
really freaks me out is the millions of
people who in 2020 and
2021 when the housing prices started to
surge
took out a big home equity loan to pay
for their new bathroom they want to get
done during that gap and now
not only is the insurance coverage not
there
but they're going to be on the hook for
that that loan they're going to be
staring at a burn down lot holding a
check that can't replace the driveway
plus you owe me us this equity loan
exactly you could what a mess if you'd
refinance the first mortgage they would
have required you to update the
insurance but many times a home equity
loan doesn't wow what a run yes you're
exactly right so you could you could
literally be upside down in the house
like like on an old days old days in a
car yeah that kind of thing so what i'm
telling you is get online a day at
ramseysolutions.com and click the elp
for insurance
and get a free quote on your car
insurance and your homeowner's insurance
and keep your homeowners insurance
updated
for the right amount of coverage because
if your house burns down and you have 50
of it covered you're going to build a
very small house in that lot
i mean you're going to be screwed up and
if you've got a mortgage you know your
mortgage is probably less than that
you're going to end up with nothing
that's zero you'll pay off the mortgage
and have a burned up lot yeah that's all
you're gonna have and so that's you're
gonna be in a mess
so make sure you keep your coverage up
to date and always price shop it with
one of these uh insurance brokers now
the difference in a broker
and somebody like state farm
one of these name brands uh you know if
they've got a uh
uh a celebrity endorser they're probably
a captive
company meaning state farm agents can
only sell state farm or a lizard
that's right
that lizard thing that's the other one
yeah um and so you can you know uh
nationwide can only sell nationwide and
so you know that they they're captive
agents that's what we call them in the
insurance business so instead you want
to get a broker that will shop a bunch
of different companies and find you the
best price in your situation
and so many times when someone goes to
rmcsolutions.com clicks on the elp
and gets with an insurance broker and
shops they not only get the right amount
of coverage because their house has gone
up in value but they also get a cheaper
rate
and uh so if you're buying the same
amount of insurance a lot of people save
seven eight hundred bucks a year by
changing their car and their homeowners
or auto and homeowners over and um
because they're just people are we're
fairly lazy
about our insurance shopping sure
uh we get it in place it's it's uh rip
it and forget it right i mean you just
put it on there and you pay the bill you
pay the pill you pay the bill unless
something comes up and shakes you up but
i'm telling you right now
i don't know what the percentage is but
i would guess
um
north of 50 of you listening to me right
now that own a home do not have the
proper amount of coverage on your home
because your home's gone up in value and
you didn't update your coverage
and the insurance companies do not
update it they are not they took that
responsibility
away from themselves and gave it to you
and having sat in this middle of a
street with somebody watching their
house burned down on a couple of
different occasions
that sounds like a nightmare on top of a
nightmare oh it is it's one of the most
horrible things to go through
emotionally and then on top of that to
not have the money to rebuild is just a
horrible thing so make sure you're
updating your insurance
ramseysolutions.com click on elp
michelle's with us in cleveland ohio hi
michelle how are you
hi dave i'm good thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um
twofold i have um
i got an esop distribution from a
company that i worked for
and it's about 1.4 million
sitting in
a schwab account it's in an ira
and i'm
with everything that's going on i'm
afraid about having all my eggs in one
basket
and my husband and i are both retired
i'm 61 he's 67
but we still have a mortgage and a home
equity line of credit
um
we don't have any credit cards we're
debt-free in the credit cards and up
until last week we had two paid off cars
but
an engine received in one of our cars so
we had to go buy a car this week um
my question is whether to given what's
going on in the world and you know the
great reset i was just watching i have
glenn beck's book and i was just
watching your program that aired today
um
i'm just a little afraid
obviously of having all my eggs in one
basket
and given what's going on in the world
if we should just
take i think there's about 160 000 that
we could take out in cash and just pay
everything off you should do that anyway
but not because of the fear of what's
going on in the world it's a smart
financial move
you're sure you've heard me you've got a
million dollars you should not be
carrying around a home mortgage with a
couple hundred grand you ought to be
paying it off
okay well that was that was my thought
process too but not because not because
of the great reset just because it's
smart to pay off your mortgage
okay okay then and same thing never
borrow money on car again you're a
millionaire come on girl
i know i was planning on paying it off
next year oh how about just never
borrowing on a car again
you're not a broke person you're a
millionaire
now with the rest of the money with the
rest of the money what i would do is sit
down with a smart vester pro click
ramsey solutions and click smart buster
pro and find somebody in the investment
business that can help you do a rollover
and get that diversified across several
types of mutual funds and give you a
little more safety
yeah i'm with you i would not have it
all in one account but i'm not sure what
you've got with schwab there necessarily
you may not really be in one account but
i'd be in several different mutual funds
with that much money and i'd be
debt-free
go borrow money on cars you're a
millionaire
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
thank you for joining us in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
larry and kamisha are with us hey guys
how are you hey dave how are you how's
it going welcome where do you guys live
we currently live in fayetteville north
carolina and we just moved there from
tallahassee florida
all right fun fun well welcome to
nashville all the way here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off sixty thousand five hundred and
sixty three dollars love it now you were
counting right how long did this take 20
months
good for you and your range of income
during that time when we first started
this journey it was 84 000 and when we
ended it was 116 000. wow nice jump good
job what do y'all do for a living i'm a
program director working with people
with intellectual and developmental
disabilities and i'm a business analyst
at a university okay very good good for
you guys what kind of debt was the 61
000 oh
credit cards student loans
car payment
or car loan
we had a college loan well it wasn't a
loan it was parking tickets oh and so
that's close to college campuses i love
the university
man they'll get you that so that's
an extra tax on the university yeah so
you guys were normal oh yeah how long
have you been married be four years in
june yep all right so what happened two
years ago halfway into this marriage and
you went uh-uh something got to change
what happened what was what was the the
deal breaker that got you on this ramsey
stuff the deal breaker i think on our
honeymoon we had the biggest argument
ever oh
no we hadn't talked about money much
and so it just came out and we just had
a huge money argument and
it was just like man it was a wake-up
call like man who was wrong
i wasn't
clearly
clearly that is a clearly you are wise
he's wiser than fighting on his
honeymoon
yeah all right yeah i had to you know
just make some decisions
there you go and so what happened what
happened 20 months ago i got you on this
plan so i've been talking with my pastor
for a while in tallahassee and he kind
of introduced me to to dave ramsey and
the plan and i just woke me up and i'm
like man we can we can do this and so
just trying to get her on board like
let's do this this is going to really
help us and really help change our lives
and change but she was already wanting
to do it back at the honeymoon yeah at
all no no no it was the wrong oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh
oh oh
okay i was the i was the free spirit i
wanted to spin spin spin okay oh no did
she call you chief on your honeymoon
yeah it's my fault
all right so kamisha how how did he get
you
to consider this whole new way of
handling and looking at money well he
brought it to my attention and i still
was not impressed
and then one of my co-workers she
actually went through your plan and her
husband became debt free and she shared
the story with me and i said okay
lynn just told me about this you know
larry just told me about this let's give
it a try
eight months into it i still was not
convinced i still wasn't convinced yeah
we took fpu in in february of 2020 right
before the pandemic here you are a
hardship yeah
absolutely a hard sale absolutely
eight months of the 20 but what happened
then
how did you become convinced we paid off
our credit cards
she started seeing results ah started
seeing the results and it was worth it
you started saying it was worth it yeah
absolutely and believing you were
actually going to make it yes clearly we
were so busy because we're both in
school so we're both in school getting
our masters and we have a three-year-old
and just trying to balance everything
we're both graduating this semester
so what are your master's in i'm getting
my master's in master's in public
administration and autism spectrum
disorders oh yeah beautiful wow
and hey there's nothing like a pandemic
to pucker up a university business
analyst right there you go there you go
there you go wide open wow i've got some
buddies that were so wet still sweating
right
like hey we should probably get out of
debt absolutely so it was definitely a
wake-up call and you know we were on on
track ahead of time and then you know
with that pandemic hit it was like our
last two classes of fpu we we did remote
and so it's like man this we have to
really pay off this debt wow it goes
full steam ahead
so i'm guessing that neither of you had
a picture growing up of
what debt-free living looked like
absolutely not no not not too much i
know my parents uh you know we were in
good position and really prepared us but
really not that you know for this
debt-free journey was something new uh
for us but i knew it was you know it was
our purpose what do you think
man you got a three-year-old
tell me about what you're thinking about
having a three-year-old that will never
understand that level of stress will
never understand not being completely
and totally free we look at her with so
much gratitude and we were just talking
about her today and we said she's so
blessed she doesn't know the things that
she won't get to experience you know
that we were able to protect her from
just by going through this journey wow
absolutely change the family tree so
will you ever go back in that oh no no
no no
no credit cards we actually um when we
took the fpu class he was the only one
to cut up his credit card like first day
and we cut the credit card and we have
not used credit cards since did you hit
him on the way home in the car no no i
was impressed
yeah
and we just finished leading fpu um as
well we just finished our week nine was
on sunday wow thank you meeting our
class thank you so much it's a new place
in fayetteville
cool
well thank you for doing that well you
guys are star pupils no question about
it i'm proud of you thank you very very
well done absolutely now that you're 100
free
and you're on the same page
how's it feel
it's gratitude it just feels i'm just
i'm grateful
i'm so grateful uh just to to be able to
lead my family
um into greater pasture and to know that
i'm really uh walking this thing that
you know the call of life that god
really designed us to walk it the right
way and to not be a borrower anymore uh
never again so uh we're on this journey
together i love it making it happen yeah
it i like it all right camisha what
what's one thing
uh
you can give us that a husband can tell
his wife when she's like i'm eight
months in i'm not doing this
give me give give america one line
be patient
be patient and to the wives i would say
you know trust your spouse um i was so
afraid i had fomo fear of missing out i
didn't want to let go of things and i
had to just let go and just trust him
because he was trying to lead us in the
right direction but i was worrying about
my status and you know wanting to get my
nails done and wanting to go out to eat
but it was bigger than that and so he
had the vision from the beginning and i
just had to trust him and trust the
process and now you can get your nails
done and go out to eat whenever you want
anytime you want you got no debt i love
it
absolutely live like no one else later
you can live and give like no way
all right now when you're teaching the
class what are you telling the key to
getting out of debt is
for me it was just really losing your
reputation
i think i really had to lose my
reputation of you know having this
status of having these things and it's
not about that anymore and i had to
really figure out a new reputation my
reputation was to you know
lead my family in the right direction um
also i just had to stop listening to
know how to start listening to broke
people yeah she doesn't like me to say
that but i really had to stop listening
to broke people like if i didn't want to
trade places with you i'm not listening
to your advice
so really you know just studying god's
word and listening to you know your
podcast every day really kept you know
keep us motivated and staying on track
in the right direction you guys are
amazing you're an absolute power couple
we're so proud of you thank you
well done we got a copy of the baby
steps millionaires book for you that's
definitely the next chapter in your
story you are on your way very well done
and a copy of total money makeover you
can give that away to somebody and stir
up a holy ruckus oh yes i like it i like
it all right it's larry and camisha they
paid off 61 000 in 20 months quite an
adventure making 84-116
count it down let's hear a dead free
scream
three
two one we're done
[Music]
i don't care who you are that's fun
oh man stop taking advice from broke
people if i don't want to trade places
with you i'm not interested in what you
have to say
how about my that will preach about my
parenting about my marriage about my
money i don't want what you have no
thank you i will pass on that i like it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day first
corinthians 10 13 no temptation has
overtaken you except what is common to
mankind and god is faithful he will not
let you be tempted beyond what you can
bear
but when you are tempted he will also
provide a way out so that you can endure
it
abraham lincoln said discipline is
choosing between what you want now and
what you want most ouch ooh that's good
travis is with us in charlotte north
carolina hi travis welcome to the ramsey
show
yes sir how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
uh first off i need to say thank you i
feel like you and your team and your
plan
has definitely saved my marriage
so i'm active military and we are
getting ready to sell our house which
the profit from selling our house we
will pay off all our debt and then have
roughly about fifty thousand dollars
left wow very cool um
so with that being said we're you know
we're moving because of the military so
we're moving from charlotte area to west
virginia um so we'll be taking a pay cut
um and we'll be debt-free so with that
extra 50 000 is that something i've
talked to a couple of financial advisors
is that something that we put towards
the house we'll be using a va loan to
purchase a house i've talked with others
that say you know to put it in a roth
ira
i've talked to a couple that say it's
not a bad idea to always invest in you
know gold and silver
so i'm just kind of curious what to do
with that amount of money uh because
we've been in debt uh just forever so
we're we're kind of going into no man's
land yeah well thanks for your service
so um how long will you be stationed in
west virginia
um
hopefully it's my last move
but probably around five years
okay
all right
um well be careful when you buy a home
there
that you um
that you buy in an area that is hot
enough that you can resell it because
i'm assuming after five years you're not
going to stay in west virginia am i
right
that's correct okay so i mean you need
to be able to get rid of this house when
you leave and so if you buy in an area
that is um
that is slow moving in real estate it's
not going to go up enough in value and
you're going to have trouble getting rid
of it so be careful of that do some
studying with the real estate agent when
you are
picking the area okay
okay so that's thing one thing two
uh uh you're you're not disabled because
you're still active duty right
uh correct the i am yes okay so the va
loan is not your best deal
it's it's more expensive than a fannie
mae loan
it's a it is a a benefit to
veterans into active duty and it should
be since it is supposed to be a way to
honor you guys and gals for serving it
should be cheaper but it's actually more
expensive than an fha or more expensive
than a fannie mae even yet and so i
would do a conventional loan and
if you want to you know pick out a
realtor that we suggest just click on
real estate elp under ramsey trusted
ramseysolutions.com you can find the
real estate agent they'll help you line
all that out and they'll show you the
numbers i'm talking about
but the the va loan
has been sold to you as part of your
package and it's something that was
supposed to be good for you
uh but they're so stupid in how they run
it as you can imagine that it's more
expensive so i wouldn't go that route so
that that's thing one uh then the last
piece is i'm going to put all the money
towards the house other than debt free
and have an emergency fund because i'm
going to put as much down as i can
because we have the goal of getting the
home paid off even if you're going to
move
later if you have a huge equity because
you paid down the home aggressively and
use this down payment you're going to
get all that money out of the house when
you sell it
so put as much down as you can
and whoever the advisor was that told
you to buy silver or gold never go near
them again yeah don't
don't drink beer with them don't mow
their yard just walk away man
yeah here's why i just pulled this
number as a matter of fact i hadn't
looked at it in a while but i pulled it
because of something else i was doing
today
uh i was on my friend glenn beck's show
and he's a big gold bug and
um the last 10 years
um
gold has an average annual rate of
return of 3.7
and the stock market has an average of
12.4 percent
that's why i'm telling you to run from
people suggesting gold
okay
and so i i do not invest in precious
metals of any kind ever
i invest in real estate that i pay cash
for and i invest in good growth stock
mutual funds
that a good smart vester pro at ramsey
solutions can hook you up with we're not
in the real estate business and we're
not in the investment business but we'll
hook up with people that will help you
do the thing you're trying to do
purchase a piece of real estate make the
investments the way that we teach
consistent
with the way we teach alan is with us in
lexington hi alan your question
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
um
yeah
my son
is staying with us right now and he has
been going through severe depression as
a result
he uh
he quit his job uh he's from alabama but
he quit his job alabama he's working
with boeing and um
he had credit card debt couldn't keep up
with his credit card payments and so
they turned over to collection agency
which then went to a lawyer and so we're
tr we came up because i've listened to
you a lot so we came up with an amount
we would pay them
and he's fifteen thousand dollars in
debt we came up with an amount we would
pay them they would not even talk to us
they said they had to talk to a lawyer
through us
and so i'm just wondering where to go
from here
well that's absolute horse crap yeah
that's not true that's just not true
[Laughter]
now they're not allowed to talk to you
about his account
they have to talk to him about his
account unless they have a legal
document allowing them to uh discuss
with you but they don't really want that
document because they don't want to talk
to they want to bully him and they've
already figured out they can't bully you
yeah they may be talking about power of
attorney for you to speak on his behalf
of his account
um right yeah because they don't they
cannot disclose stuff about his account
because he's an adult to another adult
without his permission it's violation of
federal privacy act
right but they don't but they don't have
to go through a lawyer to have this
discussion now power of attorney
if you misunderstood or they
misunderstood that yeah you'd have to
get a power of attorney
a special power of attorney allowing you
to negotiate this on his behalf
um and you know we used to do some of
that negotiating stuff on behalf of
customers that we were coaching them and
so we would have people sign this power
of attorney and we would send it to the
people
but the clerk the creditors they they
hate it because they then they found
somebody they can't bully
um and their goal is to bully him so
what what state of mind is he in right
now
he's gotten a lot better he's got he's
um he's working with a therapist and uh
could he mock you up five minutes of bad
ass to get on the phone and bust him
i think he could right now yes and see
the other reason they want to talk to us
is there's several of us on there to
talk to them and they they said we
cannot take conference calls so well
then they said and we can't talk to you
know talk to him unless he's through a
lawyer so that's nonsense that's just
not true so here's what i would do i
would have him
um
practice this with his counselor and
this can be a really big breakthrough
moment for him practice the conversation
and have him tell his counselor i want
to practice this because i'm going to be
calling this credit card company that is
i got behind and now they're raking me
over the coals heavy conflict my pulse
rate's going to go up that's right and
then that counselor is going to push on
him in a safe environment there so he
can practice this and then he can sit
with you guys and man this could be a
big win for him on multiple levels
well you're you're right and even now
his counselor has actually pushed him
into actually calling
this lawyer i mean for a long time he
just ignored he i mean it was so bad at
one time he just curled up in bed and
stayed there okay and he has come a long
way
if you're able to i want you to high
five
just that one statement you gave me
tells me that that counselor is worth
their weight in gold and if you ever
have a chance high five that counselor
there's so many folks that just want to
sit and chat
and sit and talk and this counselor is
pushing him to get out there and take
some action that's such a beautiful
thing i'm so glad that you you found a
therapist that is doing that for you
high correlation between this type of
action and recovery on depression love
it love it love it love it now very good
keep fighting keep fighting but the
answer is no that no one has to have a
lawyer to deal with a stupid credit card
company they're just a super credit card
company believe me they're dumber than a
rock
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you